tell me about about bringing the team
together you know because that's what's
great about watching the Kickstarter
video is seeing the enthusiasm the
passion your ability your ability to
inspire others and certainly it's that
energy that brought care and I here
today can you take us into your
mentality and a little bit into that
world I think especially with it with
any project um people can recognize and
feed off of your passion and it's either
going to be implosion or an explosion of
passion one or the other and for me I
try to I don't let myself wear my heart
on the sleeve all the time you're not I
mean as a writer I don't you know what I
mean you have to think analytical and
you know plan ahead and things like that
but when it's time when a shoot time my
heart is almost leave and you're gonna
know exactly how much I care about this
and I think when reaching out to people
like people Ani and Isaac Montgomery and
different people on the staff and I
think that was the one thing I like to
think it was the project not me that
brought everybody to it but then I hope
I add to it you know and I love to have
a good crew you know nice people and
people who all you know enjoy the
project and are passionate about it and
um you know I try to let that blend
things I don't stress on my set I have
fun on my set I'm living the dream I'm
doing what I wanted to do more than
anything so how could that be
you know stressful or something that I
don't want to do so you know I I just
make sure to share that I'm having fun
the man I sink or swim I could sink and
be having fun cuz this is the most did
there's been times in my life where I've
been starving starving interning you
know at a recording studio I was on
didn't have I had a job on the weekends
I could only work for two days and that
covered the transit to get back and
forth to school it didn't cover eating
didn't cover that so I I went to school
audio school and I interned at a record
label after that and then I you know and
then I went back to the same studio that
I was interning I actually went to
school studio internship and then record
label internship it went back to the
studio when I slept in the lounge and I
did that for a year the the whole you
that I
- audio school to become an engineer I
basically just slept at the studio I was
interning at and you know and you know I
remember being broke I remember being
hungry all the time but never ever ever
being happier because I was doing what I
wanted to do and you know and to me
that's what matters in life is just
doing what makes you happy so you know
if anything I hope that's what people
get from me is that I'm happy doing what
I'm doing you know if I'm doing a
project and I ever and I'm into
something I'm all in it you know and I'm
gonna be there I'm gonna be ever present
on it I'm gonna represent it I'm gonna
champion it and that's gonna be me until
you know the project runs its course and
and then I'll grab the next one so you
know hopefully that's whether that's
what people get for me and we've got a
great crew a lot of people that are
really excited to make this film happen
and you know I hope the public feeds off
of our passion and our desire to make
this film and I think we can all do it
together a byline of it guys down down
are working with us like Pete the other
guys are part of the food they've done a
lot at big films a lot of big films and
again the reason they want to work with
us because one reason because of him and
I'm hearing you say it but which is
because of him and because of the
project you know so yeah that's cool I
mean the team is definitely getting
better and stronger with every project
so I look forward to this I mean
filmmaking is not something that I just
jumped into and just thought I am gonna
be a filmmaker I walked into it like
baby steps like hey you do this thing
are you sure so each project for me was
like I learned and it was just like I
want to see what and something in myself
too to tell me that I can make a feature
film
so each short for me was something that
I needed to see for myself you know what
I mean and each one I kind of learn
something in anger because I wouldn't be
doing this film unless I thought I was
ready I wouldn't be going out that you
know
and really into the public and try to
present this unless I felt I was ready
but it's because of every project that
I've worked on I've gradually gained
knowledge and I've shown myself what I
need to see in order to gain the
confidence that I could shoot this film
so you know I I invite the public look
at my past works you know look at the
wait look at the redemption and then the
trail of the amber and if you think you
know I've grown enough to be a filmmaker
and if I'm ready for the step then help
us out
you